and and I had this thought I had this
thought with Born Again virgins I I kind
of make fun of them a little bit where
women um basically do the they they
sleep with a guy and then come out and
say oh now you were waiting for marriage
and I thought about the only way that
could work is if it's on the guy's terms
if it's on the woman's terms that does
not work men need to be in control
relationships do not work when the women
are steering them and controlling them
and so many guys just let women it's
actually so sad to see so many guys just
let women control their relationships
they go on dates where she wants to go
the house is decorated the way she wants
they they do on the they do in their
free time what she wants to do it's
never what he wants it's always what she
wants and and and these guys you know
sometimes guys I don't feel bad for you
because you guys make brats because
you're too weeny to stand up for
yourself